Yes, yes, yes. Like you, I have heard everything I ever care to hear for the rest of my life about President Clinton and his marriage. But you know, there was a brief moment, at the very beginning of the Monica Lewinsky scandal, when the public discussion included not only the questions of impeachment and lying and is it about sex, or isn't it about sex-- all that stuff-- but also questions about marriage, about how bad it is, how common it is, for people to be unfaithful to their spouses.
没错，没错，没错。和你们一样，关于克林顿总统和他的婚姻，我这辈子想听的都已经听够了。但你知道吗，在莫妮卡·莱温斯基丑闻刚爆发的那一刻，公众讨论的内容不仅包括弹劾、撒谎以及这到底是不是关乎性的问题，还包括对婚姻本身的探讨——探讨婚姻有多糟糕，探讨人们对伴侣不忠有多普遍。
And it wasn't just the Lewinsky scandal that made that happen. Around the time the Lewinsky story broke, Roy Romer, the governor of Colorado, the head of the Democratic party, publicly declared that for 16 years, he'd had a relationship outside his marriage with an aide named B.J. Thornberry. He told the press that his wife and family knew about the relationship and that they accepted it. And he argued in his press conference that it might be helpful if we would talk about what really happens in marriages, long-term marriages, instead of what we usually pretend.
促成这一讨论的不仅仅是莱温斯基丑闻。在莱温斯基事件曝光前后，科罗拉多州州长、民主党领袖罗伊·罗默公开承认，十六年来他一直与一位名叫B.J. 索恩伯里的助手保持着婚外关系。他告诉媒体，他的妻子和家人都知道这段关系并接受了它。他在新闻发布会上提出，如果我们能谈谈长期婚姻中真正发生的事情，而不是继续假装，或许会有所帮助。
Bea and I have been married 45 years. Is that right, 45? And it's a very strong relationship, solid. In the course of 45 years, in many marriages in this country, different attitudes develop in a marriage. About 50% of them end up in divorce. They can't work it out. But in those who remain married, there still are times in which there are different feelings and different relationships.
我和比阿特丽斯结婚45年了。是45年，对吧？这是一段非常牢固、坚实的关系。在这45年中，这个国家的许多婚姻里会产生不同的态度。大约50%的婚姻以离婚告终。他们无法解决问题。但在那些维持婚姻关系的人群中，依然会出现不同感受和不同关系的时刻。
All families, I think, have these kinds of problems from time to time. They handle them differently. All of you listen carefully. All of you listen carefully. I'm trying to live out a life based upon what I truly believe and truly value. Now, oftentimes, the societal norms don't fully accommodate the way I see it. I have to work that out. I'm trying to say I have conducted myself to my wife, to my children, and to B.J. in a way which I tried to be very honest and open and true to what I felt and believed.
我认为所有的家庭不时都会有这类问题。他们处理的方式各不相同。你们都要仔细听好。你们都要仔细听好。我正在努力活出基于我真正信仰和珍视之物的一生。现在，通常情况下，社会规范并不能完全包容我的看法。我必须自己去解决。我想说的是，我对妻子、对孩子、对B.J.的态度，一直都是诚实、开放的，且忠于我自己的感受和信仰。
Here is the window of discussion that's being opened up right now in our country. It came up with Roy Romer. It came up with Bill Clinton before him. And it has to do with monogamy, how to think about it. In a magazine called Critical Inquiry , a Northwestern University professor named Laura Kipnis makes the case that there are a lot of marriages where people are simply unhappy. And these people are like workers who are alienated from their jobs, numb, going nowhere.
这就是目前我们国家正在开启的讨论之窗。它始于罗伊·罗默，早于他之前还有比尔·克林顿。这与一夫一妻制有关，关乎我们如何看待它。在《批评探索》杂志上，西北大学教授劳拉·基普尼斯指出，许多婚姻中，人们仅仅是处于不快乐的状态。这些人就像工作中被异化的员工，麻木，毫无前途。
You know, we're told these days that we're supposed to work at marriage the way that we're supposed to work at a job. And so you work your job, and you work at home. And what do you get? And for these people in unfulfilling marriages, she says, having an affair is like a wildcat strike. It's an action, a civil action, a small attempt at altering the business-as-usual of their own lives.
你知道，如今人们告诉我们，婚姻应该像工作一样去经营。所以你在单位工作，回到家也要“经营”。你得到了什么？对于那些处于不幸婚姻中的人，她说，发生外遇就像是一场野猫罢工。这是一种行动，一种公民行动，一种试图改变自己生活一成不变状态的小尝试。
All the norms that people feel are the ones that you have to subscribe to and live up to don't work for a lot of people. And I think that's what's so interesting about politician adultery, is that everybody's very morally punitive about it, or that's kind of the usual way of talking about it. But nobody really talks about, well, why are these guys risking their careers and having these affairs? These guys who are supposed to be so streetwise and savvy and canny in every way, putting everything on the line.
人们感到自己必须遵守和达到的所有规范，对许多人来说并不奏效。我认为政治家通奸之所以如此有趣，是因为每个人对此都表现得非常道德惩戒，或者说那是通常的谈论方式。但没人真正谈论，为什么这些人要拿自己的事业去冒险搞这些外遇？这些人理应在各方面都老练、精明、机警，却把一切都押上了赌桌。
So and why?
那为什么呢？
Well, I guess what I'm saying is that one, people are trawling around for ways to somehow improve the quality of their life, that people feel, in a lot of cases, that they're somehow not getting what they should be getting, that normal life and the couple form, it just doesn't deliver what it's supposed to. It doesn't cover everything. It doesn't work. It doesn't make people happy. I know that sounds a little banal. It doesn't seem to say enough. But I guess I think happiness is a pretty big question. And it's one that there just are very few ways of talking about. And I think that's what's so interesting about what's going on now, because it's opening up this way to talk about things that are just never talked about. What would it be like if politicians talked about, really, the fabric of people's daily lives, what it would take to be happy, what it would take to be fulfilled?
嗯，我想说的是，第一，人们在四处寻找改善生活质量的方法。在很多情况下，人们觉得自己没有得到他们本应得到的东西，普通的生活和夫妻模式并没有交付预期的结果。它无法涵盖一切。它行不通。它不能让人快乐。我知道这听起来有点老生常谈。这似乎说得不够深入。但我想，幸福是一个非常宏大的问题。而探讨它的方式却极少。我认为这正是现在所发生的事情如此有趣的原因，因为它开启了一种谈论那些从未被谈及之事的途径。如果政治家们真的谈论人们日常生活的本质，谈论什么才能让人幸福，什么才能让人满足，那会是什么样子？
Just to summarize, I was trying to describe life as it really happens to families. And when you're in political life, there is such a hot stream of focus on you that you really do not have opportunity, the chance to say, there are tough, ambiguous things you have to decide.
总而言之，我试图描述家庭中真实发生的生活。当你身处政治生活时，那种集中的压力让你根本没有机会去说：有些棘手且暧昧的事情，你必须做出决定。
Most of us, I think, are very hesitant to believe that any kind of non-monogamous relationship can work. And Roy Romer did not have an easy press conference. The 69-year-old professional pol, a glad hand from the world of soundbites and fund-raising dinners, found himself theorizing publicly about trust and love and what marriage is.
我认为我们大多数人都非常迟疑，不敢相信任何形式的非一夫一妻制关系能够行得通。罗伊·罗默的新闻发布会并不轻松。这位69岁的职业政客，一个习惯于声音碎片和筹款晚宴的世界的人，发现自己不得不公开讨论信任、爱以及婚姻的本质。
You see, this is the issue. What is fidelity? Fidelity is what kind of openness you have, what kind of trust you have, which is based upon truth and openness. And so in my own family, we discussed that at some length. And we have tried to arrive at an understanding of what our feelings are, our needs are, and work it out with that kind of fidelity.
你看，这就是问题所在。什么是忠诚？忠诚是你拥有什么样的开放程度，什么样的信任，而这种信任基于真相和坦诚。所以在我的家庭里，我们就此进行了相当深入的讨论。我们试图达成一种共识，了解我们的感受和需求，并以那种忠诚去解决问题。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today in our program, monogamy and its discontents. Stories of people struggling to redefine monogamy, to stay monogamous, and what we should make of these ad hoc experiments in everyday life. Today, we hear case examples. Act One, Scientific Experiment, the story of a couple, the wife got a crush on another man, and how they tried to contain the crush, channel the crushy feeling, and what happens when you apply rational ideas to irrational feelings. Act Two, Love and Happiness. Dan Savage talks to real non-monogamous couples, who explain whether they're actually happy and why it might be OK to see other partners, but only if it happens in other time zones. Act Three, Istanbul. Ian Brown talks about the experience that most of us have struggling to stay monogamous, and what we should think of that struggle. Stay with us.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是“一夫一妻制及其不满”。讲述人们努力重新定义一夫一妻制、维持一夫一妻制的故事，以及我们应该如何看待这些日常生活中的临时实验。今天，我们将听到一些案例。第一幕：科学实验。讲述了一对夫妇的故事，妻子对另一个男人产生了迷恋，以及他们如何尝试控制这种迷恋，引导这种迷恋感，以及当你把理性的想法应用到非理性的感觉上时会发生什么。第二幕：爱与幸福。丹·萨维奇与真正的非一夫一妻制夫妇交谈，他们解释了自己是否真的快乐，以及为什么见其他伴侣可能是可以接受的，但前提是发生在其他时区。第三幕：伊斯坦布尔。伊恩·布朗讲述了我们大多数人在努力维持一夫一妻制时所经历的挣扎，以及我们应该如何看待这种挣扎。请继续收听。
Act One, Scientific Experiment. Well, the essential question of monogamy is what to do with feelings that you may find that you have for someone else when you're in a couple. You think you still love your spouse, and then you get this crush. You can ignore it and agonize, or you can act on it and agonize. This is the story of a couple, Sylvere and Chris. The wife, Chris, got a crush on another man. And her husband, Sylvere, suggested that she turn her crush into a kind of art project, a writing project, that they would do together. The two of them put out a magazine called Send Me a Text. And he thought maybe the writing could end up in the magazine or somewhere else.
第一幕：科学实验。嗯，一夫一妻制的核心问题在于，当你身处一段关系中时，如果你发现自己对别人产生了感觉该怎么办。你以为你仍然爱着你的配偶，然后你产生了这种迷恋。你可以忽视它并感到痛苦，或者你可以付诸行动并感到痛苦。这是一个叫西尔维尔和克里斯的夫妇的故事。妻子克里斯迷恋上了另一个男人。她的丈夫西尔维尔建议她把这种迷恋变成一种艺术项目、写作项目，他们可以一起完成。他们俩创办了一本叫《给我发短信》的杂志。他认为这些文字或许可以最终出现在杂志里或其他地方。
But a crush is a powerful thing, an irrational thing, really. Trying to contain it within an art project, within monogamy, is not so easy. Here's what happens if you try.
但迷恋是一种强大的东西，一种非理性的东西。试图把它限制在一个艺术项目中，限制在一夫一妻制内，并不容易。如果你尝试了，以下就是会发生的事情。
We started one evening, an evening like any other, which we spent as a couple with a friend, actually, somewhat of an associate of mine. And we just had dinner in a restaurant. And after that, we decided to go and have a drink at his place.
我们开始于一个傍晚，一个平淡无奇的傍晚，当时我们作为一对夫妻和一位朋友，实际上是我的一位同事，在一起。我们在餐馆吃了晚饭。之后，我们决定去他住的地方喝一杯。
Ah, dinner. Well, at dinner, I noticed that Dick was making eye contact with me across the table. And at one point in the evening, he'd looked at me, the way I was dressed. We'd met each other once or twice before. And he said, "You look as though you're really ready to come out, come out with something." Anyway, it was very strong, and it was very sexy. It was like Dick and I were speaking a secret language in front of Sylvere.
啊，晚饭。在晚餐时，我注意到迪克隔着桌子在和我进行眼神交流。在晚上某个时刻，他看着我，看着我的打扮。我们之前见过一两次面。他说：“你看上去真的很想表达，想表达点什么。”总之，那种感觉非常强烈，非常性感。就像迪克和我在西尔维尔面前说着一种秘密语言。
He lived in a desert somewhere. And it was quite a long drive through the mountains and down the desert, and then winding along roads until we reached his house, which was the last house in a little desert town, really the last stop before nowhere. And then we had an evening together, which was, I thought, pretty nice. And we got some drinks and listened to music and saw Dick's video. And it was one of these evenings that turns to be like morning.
他住在沙漠的某个地方。穿过群山，下到沙漠，沿着弯弯曲曲的路开了好长一段车，我们才到达他的房子。那是那个小沙漠镇的最后一座房子，真的是去往荒芜之地前的最后一站。然后我们一起度过了一个晚上，我觉得非常美好。我们喝了些酒，听了音乐，看了迪克的视频。那是一个像清晨一样令人难忘的夜晚。
Dick played us a video that he'd made that was commissioned by English Public Television of himself dressed as Johnny Cash, riding his horse into the heart of darkness and talking about earthquakes and longing and despair. And it was then that I fell totally in love with Dick.
迪克给我们放了他制作的一个视频，是英国公共电视台委托拍摄的。视频里他打扮成约翰尼·卡什，骑着马走进黑暗之心，谈论地震、渴望和绝望。就在那一刻，我彻底爱上了迪克。
Watching him dressed as Johnny Cash?
看着他打扮成约翰尼·卡什？
Yeah.
是的。
I was not quite aware that there was anything happening between Dick and Chris, my wife. And there was not much happening, except in her mind, I guess. And then we went to bed.
我当时不太意识到迪克和克里斯，也就是我妻子之间发生了什么。其实除了在她的脑海里，也没发生什么。然后我们就上床睡觉了。
We stumble off to bed at 2 o'clock in the morning, me and Sylvere on the sofa bed in the living room, Dick in his bedroom on the other side of the wall with the door closed. And all night long, I found myself dreaming that I had moved across the wall and I was in bed with Dick.
凌晨两点，我们跌跌撞撞地去睡觉，我和西尔维尔睡在客厅的沙发床上，迪克睡在墙另一边的卧室里，门是关着的。整个晚上，我发现自己梦见我穿过了那堵墙，和迪克躺在床上。
And in the morning-- we're on a kind of extended sofa-- and in the morning, Dick was gone. And Chris started fantasizing about the fact that he-- before realizing he was left, she fantasized about the fact that he was like smoking a cigarette in his bed. And then we discovered he was gone. And we waited a bit and then decided to go back to our place. And that was the main substance of what became an extended story.
早晨——我们睡在一种加长沙发上——早晨，迪克不见了。克里斯开始幻想，在意识到他离开之前，她幻想他正躺在床上抽烟。然后我们发现他走了。我们等了一会儿，决定回我们住的地方。那成为了后来那个长篇故事的主要内容。
We left, and we went and had breakfast at the IHOP down the road. And I couldn't stop talking about it.
我们离开了，去路边的IHOP吃了早饭。我忍不住一直谈论这件事。
We talk about all these things and things that go through our head. And I guess I pay attention to them, but I didn't pay special attention to it at that point. It didn't seem like anything real. And I didn't feel threatened by it at all.
我们谈论所有这些事情，谈论我们脑子里闪过的念头。我想我注意到了，但在那个时候并没有特别在意。它看起来不像是什么真实的事情。我一点也没觉得受到威胁。
We weren't really very sexual at that point in our relationship anymore. And the way that we compensated for the lack of sex was we would deconstruct everything. We'd tell each other everything. That's how you stay intimate with somebody. So I told Sylvere everything that had happened to me that night and everything that was on my mind. And we couldn't stop talking about it. And all the way back, we kept talking about what happened last night with Dick, last night with Dick, our night with Dick.
我们当时的关系中已经没有太多的性生活了。我们补偿缺乏性生活的方式就是解构一切。我们告诉对方所有事情。这就是你与某人保持亲密的方式。所以我告诉西尔维尔那天晚上发生在我身上的一切，以及我脑子里的一切。我们忍不住一直谈论它。回来的路上，我们不停地谈论昨晚和迪克发生的事，昨晚和迪克，我们与迪克的夜晚。
Chris has crushes once in a while. The only defense with a usual couple, I guess, is that we talk about it and laugh about it or explore it a little bit. But that's part of being together. We share everything.
克里斯偶尔会有迷恋。我想，普通夫妇的唯一防御方式就是谈论它，拿它开个玩笑，或者稍微探索一下。但这正是相处的一部分。我们分享一切。
Well, I was tormented. So I went to Sylvere, and I was, "Oh, Sylvere, what should I do? What should I do? Maybe I should write a letter." And Sylvere said, "Yes, of course. That's a great idea, Chris. I think you should write a letter. I'll help you. Let's get the computer. Let's set it up right now. We'll write a letter to Dick."
好吧，我很煎熬。所以我去找西尔维尔，我说：“噢，西尔维尔，我该怎么办？我该怎么办？也许我应该写封信。”西尔维尔说：“是的，当然。这真是个好主意，克里斯。我觉得你应该写封信。我会帮你的。我们找台电脑。现在就设置好。我们要给迪克写封信。”
Turning it into a project was turning it into something we could do together. See, I decided from the beginning I wasn't going to be jealous, because I've been through that. And I don't have any respect for it. And I don't think that marriage is a property in which you own anyone. I never agreed with myself when I felt jealous, although I recognize the emotion, which is very powerful.
把它变成一个项目，就是把它变成我们可以一起做的事情。你看，我从一开始就决定不嫉妒，因为我经历过那种感觉。我对此毫无尊重。而且我不认为婚姻是一种你可以占有任何人的财产。当我感到嫉妒时，我从不赞同我自己，尽管我认得这种情感，它非常强烈。
And so you started writing letters. And you wrote the first letter.
于是你们开始写信。你们写了第一封信。
I wrote the first letter, yes, because I knew Dick much better. And I liked the idea. I liked Dick. I liked him then, and I kind of like him now.
我写了第一封信，是的，因为我比西尔维尔更了解迪克。而且我喜欢这个主意。我喜欢迪克。我当时喜欢他，现在也挺喜欢他。
Sylvere wrote the first letter. And Sylvere wrote a really good letter. But it wasn't enough. And when Sylvere finished his letter, I knew that there were things that I could add. And his letter prompted me to write my letter. So I wrote my first letter. And then Sylvere was very critical of my first letter. And he said, "This and this and this are wrong, and you could do it better." Well, we both sat down to write the second draft, Sylvere's second letter and my second letter.
西尔维尔写了第一封信。西尔维尔写了一封非常好的信。但那还不够。当西尔维尔写完他的信时，我知道还有一些我可以补充的内容。他的信促使我写了我的信。所以我写了我的第一封信。然后西尔维尔对我的第一封信非常挑剔。他说：“这个、这个还有这个都写错了，你可以写得更好。”好吧，我们俩都坐下来写了第二稿，西尔维尔的第二封信和我的第二封信。
And the notion from the very beginning was that you would write the letters, but you would not send them?
从一开始的概念就是你们会写这些信，但不会寄出去？
No. I think the notion at the very beginning was that we would send them. But after you've written a first draft and a second draft, and then a third and a fourth and a fifth letter, and you have a stack of letters-- in fact, after three days, we had maybe 80 pages of letters-- it reaches a point where you can't possibly send the letter.
不。我认为最开始的概念是我们会寄出去。但在你写了第一稿、第二稿，然后第三、第四、第五封信，你有了一堆信之后——事实上，三天后，我们大概有了80页的信件——它达到了一个你绝对不可能把信寄出去的程度。
Well, first of all, the way we wrote the letter was the essential thing, because the idea was not to write letters in repose and think about the words. We both have a computer. And we're sitting in front of each other and basically dictating the letter to the other person.
首先，我们写信的方式是关键，因为我们的想法不是静下心来仔细斟酌词句。我们都有电脑。我们相对而坐，基本上是把信口述给对方。
OK, this is from the first letter that I wrote to Dick. "Crestline, California, December 9, 1994. Dear Dick, when you called on Sunday night, I was writing a description of your face. I couldn't talk and hung up on the bottom end of the romantic equation with beating heart and sweaty palms. It's incredible to feel this way. For 10 years, my life's been organized around avoiding this painful elemental state. Sylvere, who's typing this, says this letter lacks a point. What reaction am I looking for? He says I'm squashing out all the trembly little things he found so touching. But Dick, I know that as you read this, you'll know these things are true. Being in love with you, being ready to take this ride, made me feel 16, hunched up in a leather jacket in a corner with my friends. A timeless image. It's about not giving a [BLEEP] or seeing all the consequences looming and doing something anyway. Sylvere thinks he's that kind of anarchist. But he's not. I love you, Dick. Chris."
好的，这是我写给迪克的第一封信。“加利福尼亚州克雷斯特莱恩，1994年12月9日。亲爱的迪克，当你周日晚上打电话来时，我正在描写你的脸。我无法说话，带着剧烈的心跳和汗湿的手心，挂断了浪漫方程式的底端。感觉成这样真是不可思议。十年来，我的生活一直围绕着避免这种痛苦的原始状态。正在打字的西尔维尔说这封信没有重点。我在寻求什么反应？他说我把那些让他觉得感动的颤动的小东西都抹掉了。但迪克，我知道当你读到这些时，你会知道这些都是真的。爱上你，准备好踏上这段旅程，让我觉得自己16岁了，穿着皮夹克，和朋友们缩在角落里。一个永恒的形象。这关乎不在乎任何狗屁后果，看到所有威胁 looming 的后果却依然去做。西尔维尔以为他是那种无政府主义者。但他不是。我爱你，迪克。克里斯。”
Could you open to page 49? Most of the letters take the form of real letters, but this is a letter which takes the form of dialogue between the two of you.
能打开第49页吗？大多数信件都采取了真实信件的形式，但这封信采取了你们两人之间对话的形式。
Do you want me to read that?
你想让我读那一段吗？
Yeah. Basically, it's this dialogue between you and Chris. And yeah, could you please?
对。基本上是你和克里斯之间的这段对话。可以吗？请。
Yeah, each of us typing on a typewriter. "Chris-- Sylvere, this is like the institute of emotional research.
好的，我们每个人都在打字机上打字。“克里斯——西尔维尔，这就像情感研究所。
Sylvere-- The only way we can recapture any feeling is by evoking Dick.
西尔维尔——我们能够重获任何感觉的唯一方式就是唤起迪克。
Chris-- He's our imaginary friend.
克里斯——他是我们的想象朋友。
Sylvere-- Do we need that? It's so mixed up. At times, we reach these peaks of real possession at his expense. But through it, we're able to see him more clearly than he ever would himself.
西尔维尔——我们需要那个吗？它太混乱了。有时，我们在以牺牲他为代价的情况下达到了真实的占有巅峰。但通过这一点，我们能够比他自己更清晰地看到他。
Chris-- Don't be so presumptuous. You keep talking about Dick as if he was your little brother. You think you have his number.
克里斯——别那么自以为是。你一直谈论迪克，就好像他是你的弟弟。你以为你拿捏住了他。
Sylvere-- Well, I don't have the same take on him as you do.
西尔维尔——嗯，我对他的看法和你不一样。
Chris-- I don't have a take. I'm in love with him.
克里斯——我没有什么看法。我爱他。
Sylvere-- It's so unfair. What has he done to deserve this? 8:45 PM."
西尔维尔——这太不公平了。他做了什么值得这样？晚上8:45。”
Sylvere, as you wrote these letters, did you find most of the time that you were writing in the letters, urging Chris not to love him, or urging Chris to love him?
西尔维尔，当你们写这些信时，你发现大多数时候你们是在信中劝克里斯不要爱他，还是劝克里斯去爱他？
Well, it all depends. What happened is that I got involved in the project. And when she got too intense about it, I started being anxious about it and upset. But when, somehow, the project became elusive and we were beginning to lose the thread, then I would somehow push her to get back into it, I guess because it was a form of communing. It was a form of being together. It was a good excuse to play a game together-- the conjugal game, the jealous husband game. I don't know.
嗯，这取决于情况。发生的情况是我卷入了项目中。当她对此表现得太强烈时，我开始感到焦虑和不安。但当不知何故，这个项目变得难以捉摸，我们开始失去线索时，我就会以某种方式推她一把，让她回到状态，我想那是因为这是一种共处的方式。这是一种在一起的形式。这是一个很好的借口，可以一起玩个游戏——夫妻游戏、嫉妒的丈夫游戏。我不知道。
Do you feel like part of what writing the letters was about was trying to keep this feeling, this transgressive feeling, this crush, penned in within the bounds of your marriage vows?
你觉得写信的部分原因是试图把这种感觉，这种越轨的感觉，这种迷恋，圈在你们结婚誓言的范围内吗？
You know, we never said to ourselves, "We're going to write letters because we don't want to transgress the bounds of our marriage." We never said that. But at a certain point, Sylvere and I looked at each other and said, "This is the closest we've been in years. We're having more fun together having this adventure, writing these letters, being in love with this third person, than we've had in our entire marriage. What's threatening to tear us apart is, in fact, bringing us closer together."
你知道，我们从没对自己说：“我们要写信是因为我们不想越过婚姻的界限。”我们从没那样说。但在某个时刻，西尔维尔和我看着对方说：“这是多年来我们最亲近的时候。我们一起进行这场冒险、写这些信、爱上这第三个人，比我们整个婚姻生活中获得的乐趣都要多。真正威胁要撕裂我们关系的，实际上却让我们更亲近了。”
Sylvere fell deeply in love with me while this correspondence was going on, in a way that he had never been in love with me before. Our connection had been very intellectual, very professional. But it'd never been a grand passion or a great love. And I really felt the lack of that in my life.
西尔维尔在这场通信过程中深深地爱上了我，以一种他以前从未爱过我的方式。我们的连接一直是理性的、职业的。但从未有过伟大的激情或伟大的爱。我真的感到生活中缺乏那个。
So one of the things that happened between the two of you is, as you went through this process, your sex life returned.
所以你们两人之间发生的事情之一，就是当你们经历这个过程时，你们的性生活恢复了。
Right, which is one of the good things that can happen out of bad ones.
是的，这是坏事中可能发生的少数好事之一。
And that's a great gift.
那是一份伟大的礼物。
At the very last phase of this dual correspondence to Dick, of me and Sylvere writing letters to Dick, we were at our house in upstate New York. And we decided that our lives were a lot like Charles and Emma Bovary's, trapped in the provinces of Yonville. Sylvere decided to become Charles Bovary. So he wrote a letter to Dick as Charles Bovary, thanking him for the fact that he and I had started having sex together again.
在我和西尔维尔写给迪克的双重通信的最后阶段，我们正在纽约北部的房子里。我们觉得我们的生活很像查尔斯和艾玛·包法利，被困在永维尔省。西尔维尔决定成为查尔斯·包法利。于是他写了一封信给迪克，作为查尔斯·包法利，感谢他让我和他又能重新开始过性生活。
"Thurman, New York, January 12, 1995, Thursday. Dear Dick, this is Charles Bovary. Emma and I have been living together for some nine years. Everyone knows what this entails. Passion becomes tenderness. Tenderness turns soft. Sex became short and somewhat wobbly. We had sex rarely, pretending it didn't matter. Our love increased, and sex was sublimated to more worthy social endeavors-- art, careers, property. Still occasionally, the troubling thought surfaced that a couple without sex is hardly a couple at all. It's at this point, Dick, after we'd convinced ourselves that a life without sex was a better life, that you entered our life like an angel of mercy. Emma's desiring elsewhere enabled me to regain desire. How it happened remains a miracle. It returned suddenly about a week ago, the spirit of sex, like one of these little Roman gods, touching every part of my body, arousing them to the sacredness of pleasure, as if the veil had lifted and a new field of human possibility revealed. I dedicate this letter to you, Dick. With all my love, Charles."
“纽约瑟曼，1995年1月12日，周四。亲爱的迪克，这是查尔斯·包法利。艾玛和我在一起生活了大约九年。每个人都知道这意味着什么。激情变成了温柔。温柔变得柔软。性变得短暂且有些不稳。我们很少有性生活，假装那并不重要。我们的爱增加了，性被升华为更有价值的社会事业——艺术、事业、财产。尽管如此，偶尔还是会浮现出令人不安的想法，即没有性生活的夫妻根本算不上夫妻。迪克，就在我们说服自己没有性生活的生活才是更好的生活之后，你像一位怜悯的天使进入了我们的生活。艾玛对外的欲望使我重获欲望。它是如何发生的仍然是个奇迹。它在大约一周前突然回归，性的精神，就像这些罗马小神灵之一，触及我身体的每一部分，唤醒它们对快乐的神圣感，仿佛面纱升起，展现出一片人类可能性的新领域。我把这封信献给你，迪克。怀着我所有的爱，查尔斯。”
Do you think that Sylvere had any feelings of jealousy?
你觉得西尔维尔有嫉妒的感觉吗？
Well, of course he did. I mean, how could this happen and Sylvere not be jealous? But Sylvere is a very reasonable and reflective person. So as these emotions start to come up, like jealousy, he looks at them and says, "Well, hmm. Is that really the way I want to feel? Is that the way I want to handle this? Is that the kind of person I want to be?" And he says, "No." So then he looks around for another angle. What angle, what position could he take, that would avoid jealousy? Because jealousy-- really, to be the jealous husband, is just to be such a buffoon.
嗯，当然有。我的意思是，怎么可能发生这种事而西尔维尔不嫉妒？但西尔维尔是一个非常理性且善于反思的人。所以当这些情绪开始出现时，比如嫉妒，他审视它们并说：“嗯，嗯。这真的是我想要的感受吗？这是我想要处理的方式吗？这是我想要成为的人吗？”他说：“不。”然后他寻找另一个角度。什么角度，什么立场，可以避免嫉妒？因为嫉妒——真的，作为一个嫉妒的丈夫，简直就是个小丑。
Yes, there were moments where I felt dumped and I felt betrayed and I felt it was going too far and I wanted to backtrack. And it wasn't always possible.
是的，确实有几个时刻我觉得被抛弃了，觉得被背叛了，觉得事情进展得太远了，我想退缩。但这并不总是可能的。
Months passed. Chris kept writing love letters to Dick. The experiment of containing her feelings in a rational little art project was, in fact, unleashing her feelings. She became obsessed. She says it was like self-hypnosis. Dick never wrote back. She fell deeper and deeper in love. And as she wrote, she started to reflect on her marriage, on how she'd become an appendage to Sylvere, how she no longer had a separate life, a separate identity. She was resentful.
几个月过去了。克里斯一直给迪克写情书。把她的感情控制在一个理性的小艺术项目里的实验，实际上正在释放她的感情。她变得痴迷。她说那就像自我催眠。迪克从没回信。她越陷越深。随着书写，她开始反思自己的婚姻，反思自己是如何变成了西尔维尔的附属品，反思她如何不再有独立的生活、独立的身份。她感到怨恨。
It became a roller coaster. And you're not always in control. And of course, the marriage was at stake. And the marriage, she broke.
它变成了过山车。你并不总是能控制局面。当然，婚姻岌岌可危。而那段婚姻，她打破了。
After months of writing these letters to Dick, it became impossible for me to continue living with Sylvere the way I had.
在写了几个月给迪克的信后，我再也不可能像以前那样和西尔维尔生活下去了。
Explain that.
解释一下。
Well, OK. Things changed very drastically, because at the end of what I call the first round of letters, after we'd written about 200 pages together, I actually gave them to Dick. We were out in California, and we had another dinner with Dick. And I presented the letters to Dick. Well, Dick was gob-struck. He couldn't believe it.
好吧。事情发生了非常剧烈的变化，因为在我所谓的首轮信件结束后，在我们一起写了约200页之后，我真的把它们给了迪克。我们在加利福尼亚，又和迪克吃了一顿饭。我把信呈给了迪克。嗯，迪克惊呆了。他简直不敢相信。
What did he say? Was he horror-struck?
他说了什么？他感到惊恐吗？
No. You see, Dick had said something to me pretty early on in the correspondence. He said, "Right now, I'm at a point in my life where I'm experimenting with what it's like to never say no, to say yes to everything that comes along." So he decided not to say no to me and to my project. He didn't give me any encouragement. He didn't participate in it. But he never said no. He never said stop.
不。你看，迪克在通信初期就对我说过一些话。他说：“目前，我人生中处于一个阶段，我在尝试从不拒绝是什么感觉，对发生的一切都说好。”所以他决定不对我和我的项目说不。他没有给我任何鼓励。他没有参与其中。但他从没说不。他从没说停。
We had a house in upstate New York, and I moved up there alone that winter to be alone to write to Dick. And I called Dick, and I told him that I'd left my husband and that I really wanted to see him alone, and could I come out and spend a weekend with him. Well, he said yes. He said, "I won't say no."
我们在纽约北部有一栋房子，那个冬天我独自搬到那里去写信给迪克。我给迪克打了电话，告诉他我离开了丈夫，我真的很想单独见他，我能去和他过个周末吗。他答应了。他说：“我不会说不。”
When she actually met Dick, I was out of my mind, of course. So.
当她真的见到迪克时，我当然快疯了。所以。
Well, the plan was that I was going to drive out to his place as soon as I got off the plane. And I did that. It was a Thursday night. It was raining. I was terribly nervous. I'd changed clothes two or three times-- on the plane, in the rental car office. And I got to Dick's house. And he was there. And I saw him through the plate-glass window. And he was deep in thought. He was grading papers. And I knocked on the door, and he answered it. And he brushed me very lightly on the side of the cheek. And I came in. We had a drink.
嗯，计划是我一下飞机就开车去他住的地方。我也确实那么做了。那是一个周四晚上。下着雨。我紧张得要命。我换了两三次衣服——在飞机上，在租车办公室。我到达了迪克的家。他在那里。我透过落地窗看到了他。他陷入了沉思。他在批改试卷。我敲了门，他应了。他轻轻地拂过我的脸颊。我进去了。我们喝了杯酒。
And very soon, the conversation came around to him asking me, "Why are you here?" He started attacking me. And he said, "I think you're demonic and psychotic." He started screaming at me. "You don't know me. We've had two or three evenings, talked on the phone once or twice. And you project this [BLEEP] over me. You kidnap me. You stalk me, invade me with your games. And I don't want it. I never asked for it. I think you're evil and psychotic." I didn't know what to do. I was completely devastated.
很快，谈话就转到了他问我：“你为什么在这？”他开始攻击我。他说：“我觉得你又疯又神经质。”他开始冲我大喊大叫。“你不了解我。我们见过两三次面，通过一两次电话。你就把这些[哔]投影到我身上。你绑架我，跟踪我，用你的游戏入侵我。我不想要这样。我从来没要求过。我觉得你既邪恶又神经质。”我不知道该怎么办。我完全崩溃了。
Except for the evil and psychotic part, do you see why he would say, "You don't know who I am, and we've only spent a couple of times together, and you've imagined this intense thing?"
除了邪恶和神经质那部分，你明白他为什么要说“你不了解我是谁，我们只见过几次面，你却想象出了这种强烈的事情”吗？
Well, yes. I suppose on a certain level, he had his point. He had his point. But he was so resolutely and methodically cruel to me. There was a definite turning moment, where he just decided to kind of play things a different way.
嗯，明白。我想在某种程度上，他有他的道理。他有他的道理。但他对我如此坚定且刻意地残忍。有一个明确的转折点，他决定以不同的方式来处理事情。
I asked him if he wanted to see me again over the weekend. And he turned to me and said, "I don't know. Do you want to?" And I said, "Yes, I do. Absolutely. Definitely." And he started repeating my words, "Yes. Definitely. Absolutely." And then he said, "Well, I'm sorry. I have a friend coming into town for the weekend." And he made this friend sound like, of course, a longstanding affair from way back. So when he saw that I was disappointed, he jumped on me. And he said, "What's the matter? Did I burst your balloon, destroy the fantasy?"
我问他周末想不想再见到我。他转向我说：“我不知道。你想吗？”我说：“是的，我想。绝对，肯定是。”他开始重复我的话，“是的。肯定。绝对。”然后他说：“好吧，很抱歉。我有位朋友周末要到镇上来。”他让这位朋友听起来好像当然是从很久以前就保持着长期关系。所以当他看到我失望时，他猛地攻击我。他说：“怎么了？我戳破了你的气球，摧毁了你的幻想吗？”
Sylvere, one way to read this story of what happened is that Chris had a crush. And by having her write all these letters, by encouraging her to write all these letters, that you unconsciously, perhaps, created a situation where she would have all these things to present to Dick, and he would reject her.
西尔维尔，读这个故事的一种方式是，克里斯有了迷恋。而通过让她写所有这些信，通过鼓励她写所有这些信，你是否在无意识中创造了一种情况，让她有所有这些东西呈给迪克，然后他拒绝了她？
Maybe you're right in the sense that both of us started writing letters, making it very difficult for him to have a position in relation to it. It wasn't as if something was happening between him and a woman. It was a whole marriage that was coming down on his knees. That's what you mean. And I think it's right. And I guess it was something in the back of my mind, yes. As long as we made it a project and we were together, that started in such a way that may have made it impossible to turn into a private affair, because it was, to start with, so public.
也许你是对的，在这种意义上，我们俩都开始写信，使得他很难在其中找到一个定位。这不像是他和某个女人之间发生了什么。而是整个婚姻都在他面前跪下了。你是指这个。我想你是对的。我想这在我脑海深处确实存在，是的。只要我们把它变成一个项目，只要我们在一起，这种开始方式可能使得它不可能变成一段私人婚外情，因为它从一开始就是如此公开。
After some time, Chris and Sylvere were reconciled. They're still married, but their jobs have now taken them to opposite sides of the country. He lives on the East Coast. She lives on the West. They talk every day, or nearly every day. They lean on each other, share their lives. And for now, they're non-monogamous. Each of them sees other people from time to time.
一段时间后，克里斯和西尔维尔和好了。他们仍然结婚，但现在的工作把他们带到了国家的两端。他住在东海岸。她住在西海岸。他们每天或几乎每天都会交谈。他们相互依赖，分享生活。而目前，他们是非一夫一妻制的。他们每人偶尔都会见其他人。
We married, and things keep changing. In a sense, we see each other for a week once a month, sometimes more, sometimes less. And we spend time together. We enjoy being together. Most often, we feel very close. And we manage, I guess, after a few years, to keep this closeness in spite of other involvements that we are in. Some of them may be final. We don't know. It's a very shaky proposition, in the sense that you get carried away by the situation you're in. We live in totally different situations. So the risk is always there that something is going to happen and make it final.
我们结婚了，事情在不断变化。在某种意义上，我们每月见一次面，大概一周，有时更多，有时更少。我们花时间在一起。我们享受相处的时光。大多数时候，我们感觉很亲近。我想几年下来，我们设法在其他的纠葛中保持了这种亲近。其中一些可能是最终的。我们不知道。这是一个非常动摇的主张，因为你会沉溺于你所处的境况中。我们生活在完全不同的环境下。所以风险总是存在，可能会发生什么让一切成为定局。
It's after having gone through this experience together-- and at every moment, really, we were in it together. In all of my pain, in all of his pain, we were there together with each other, because we didn't have any other way of being. After going through that, well, it just seems inevitable to us that, one way or another, we will be intimately connected. We will be responsible for each other for the rest of our lives.
在共同经历了这段体验之后——在每一刻，我们确实是一起经历的。在我所有的痛苦中，在他所有的痛苦中，我们彼此陪伴，因为我们没有其他相处方式。经历了这一切，嗯，对我们来说，似乎无论如何，我们将保持亲密的连接。我们将终身对彼此负责。
When you think about this whole experience, what do you think you learned from it?
当你思考整个这段经历时，你认为你从中学会了什么？
What do I think I learned from it?
我认为我学会了什么？
Yeah.
对。
Well, I learned that you have to pay for indulgence, because, at some level, it was also indulgent. It was a project. It was a risky operation. It was also playing with fire.
嗯，我学会了你必须为放纵买单，因为在某种程度上，这也是放纵。这是一个项目。这是一次冒险的操作。这同时也是在玩火。
I think the thing that most of us find so threatening about a non-monogamous relationship is we just don't want to have to go through the jealousy.
我想我们大多数人对非一夫一妻制关系感到如此威胁的原因是，我们只是不想必须去经历嫉妒。
I know. But I guess if you've been through the jealousy to the extent that I have been and I'm sure other people have been, and you learn from it. And what you learn is that there are ways of avoiding it. And one of the ways is not try to imagine what the other person is doing and try not to have images or to focus on that. And you realize that the partner can very well have a life. And you don't have to take it as something that concerns you. See, it concerns the person. It's not done to do you harm. It's not done to betray you. It's done because the other person has a life.
我知道。但我想如果你已经像我一样，我相信其他人也经历过那样程度的嫉妒，你会从中学习。而你学到的是，有办法避免它。其中一种方法就是不要试图想象对方在做什么，尽量不要去关注那个。你意识到伴侣完全可以有自己的生活。你不必把它当作关乎你的事情。你看，它关乎那个人。它不是为了伤害你而做的。它不是为了背叛你而做的。它之所以做，是因为对方有自己的生活。
The whole question of faithfulness and fidelity seems so-- I don't know, small, compared to loyalty and a lifetime commitment to another person.
整个关于忠诚和信实的问题似乎……我不知道，与对另一个人的忠诚和终身承诺相比，显得太小了。
Sylvere Lotringer and Chris Kraus. She collected their letters, plus an account of what happened, in a book called I Love Dick, published by Semiotext(e).
西尔维尔·洛特林格和克里斯·克劳斯。她将他们的信件以及对发生之事的描述汇编成了一本名为《我爱迪克》的书，由Semiotext(e)出版社出版。
Coming up, 82 monogamous couples, 82 non-monogamous couples. Who's happier? Who's more likely to stay married? Answers, real answers, in a minute, from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，82对一夫一妻制夫妇，82对非一夫一妻制夫妇。谁更快乐？谁更有可能维持婚姻？答案，真实的答案，稍后，我们的节目继续，来自国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers, performers and other people to come on and tell us stories on that theme. Today's program, monogamy and its discontents, people struggling with monogamy, grasping for alternatives. We have reached the second act of our program, Act Two, Love and Happiness.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，当然，我们会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、表演者和其他人来讲述这个主题的故事。今天的节目，“一夫一妻制及其不满”，人们在一夫一妻制中挣扎，寻求替代方案。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕，第二幕：爱与幸福。
I think, for most of us, our first reaction when we hear about non-monogamous arrangements that couples sometimes have is that queasy feeling you get when you hear about somebody's life that you would not want to ever be your own. How can these people possibly be happy? In this act, Dan Savage explains. A warning before he begins-- he talks about sex in this story. Nothing explicit or graphic, but the subject does come up.
我想，对于我们大多数人来说，当我们听说夫妻之间有时采取非一夫一妻制的安排时，第一反应就是当你听说别人的生活而你绝不希望那是你自己的生活时所产生的那种恶心感。这些人怎么可能快乐？在这一幕中，丹·萨维奇将为您解释。在开始之前请注意——他在这个故事中谈到了性。没有露骨或色情的内容，但确实提到了这个话题。
With apologies to Leo Tolstoy, monogamous couples are all alike. Each non-monogamous couple is non-monogamous in its own way. For a non-monogamous arrangement to function properly-- "properly" meaning no blood, no tears-- both persons involved have to agree on a set of rules. The rules of monogamy are pretty simple and straightforward. After you've said, "Honey, let's not have sex with other people," what's left to discuss?
引用列夫·托尔斯泰的话，一夫一妻制的夫妻都是相似的。每个非一夫一妻制的夫妻都有各自不同的非一夫一妻方式。为了让非一夫一妻制的安排正常运作——“正常”意味着没有血泪——双方必须同意一套规则。一夫一妻制的规则非常简单直观。在你说了“亲爱的，我们不要和别人发生性关系”之后，还有什么好讨论的？
But functional non-monogamy, the having of sex with persons other than your partner, with your partner's foreknowledge and consent, well, that sort of an arrangement requires some delicate negotiation. If it's OK with you for your partner to have sex with other people, does that mean it's OK for your partner to have sex with other people under any circumstances? In the bed you share? With your best friend? Probably not. And that's where the rules come in.
但功能性的非一夫一妻制，即在伴侣知情并同意的情况下与他人发生性关系，嗯，这种安排需要一些微妙的谈判。如果你同意你的伴侣与他人发生性关系，这是否意味着在任何情况下都可以？在你共享的床上？和你的好友？大概不行。这就是规则发挥作用的地方。
The rules vary from couple to couple. I've heard of couples who weren't allowed to sleep with each other's friends or with their exes. Not in our apartment, house, bed, is a common one. I've been in three non-monogamous relationships. In one, we could sleep with other people so long as we weren't in the same time zone. In another, outside encounters were limited to a certain few and very specific sex acts that, for a certain few and very specific reasons, we didn't enjoy doing together. One straight couple I recently heard about has a rule that requires them to lie to each other. Not just lie, but lie convincingly. The idea seems to be that it's OK if they sleep with other people. They're just not allowed to make the other person feel bad by actually letting them know about it. A clumsy lie would be as bad as telling them. I interviewed one woman who was in a non-monogamous relationship for three years.
规则因人而异。我听说过一些夫妇不允许与对方的朋友或前任发生关系。不可以在我们的公寓、房子、床上，这很常见。我曾有过三段非一夫一妻制的关系。在其中一段，我们可以和别人睡觉，只要我们不在同一个时区。在另一段，外部邂逅仅限于特定的几个人和非常特定的性行为，因为特定的几个特定的原因，我们在一起不享受做那些。我最近听说的一对异性恋夫妇有一条规则，要求他们互相撒谎。不是简单的撒谎，而是令人信服地撒谎。这个想法似乎是，如果他们和别人睡觉是可以的。只是不允许通过实际上让他们知道这件事而让对方感到难受。拙劣的谎言和直接告诉他们一样糟糕。我采访过一位处于非一夫一妻制关系三年的女性。
The rules were very jokey. The rules were mostly centered around making sure that nobody got involved with somebody who was better than the person they're already involved with, which was each other. So I wouldn't want him to have sex with someone who was terribly sexy or smart or witty or funny--
规则非常像开玩笑。规则主要集中在确保没有人与比他们已经与之交往的人更好的人发生关系，也就是彼此。所以我不希望他与一个非常性感、聪明、机智或有趣的人发生性关系——
So nobody sexier, smarter, wittier, or funnier than you.
所以没人能比你更性感、更聪明、更机智或更有趣。
No, they all had to be a little bit lame.
不，他们都得稍微差劲一点。
The rules seem to fall into three broad categories-- who you can have sex with, under what circumstances, and what you can tell your partner about it. It's that third set of rules that are the stickiest. How much do you want to know? If your partner has sex with a tree in a forest and you're not around to hear it, did it actually happen?
这些规则似乎分为三大类——你可以和谁发生性关系，在什么情况下，以及你可以告诉你的伴侣多少。第三套规则是最棘手的。你想知道多少？如果你的伴侣和森林里的一棵树发生了性关系，而你不在现场听到，那它真的发生了吗？
The woman I interviewed made a non-disclosure pact with her boyfriend. But ultimately, they couldn't live up to their "don't ask, don't tell" policy. They began sharing their experiences with each other, which resulted in competition. If one got some on the side, the other felt entitled and would go looking for it. Breaking their own "don't ask, don't tell" rule was complicating their arrangement, which begs the biggest question of all. Do these non-monogamous arrangements work? Was this couple happy?
我采访的那位女性和她的男友达成了不公开协议。但最终，他们无法履行“不问不说”的政策。他们开始分享彼此的经历，导致了竞争。如果一个人在外面得到了满足，另一个人就会感到有权也去寻找。打破他们自己的“不问不说”规则让他们的安排变得复杂，这引出了最大的问题。这些非一夫一妻制的安排有效吗？那对夫妇快乐吗？
Well, it worked and it didn't work. There was a part of me that felt like being non-monogamous sort of created this hollow core in the center of the relationship. Like I really loved this person, but I wasn't sure I could trust him as far as I could throw him.
嗯，它有效也没效。我的一部分感觉非一夫一妻制在某种程度上在关系的核心创造了一个空洞。就像我真的很爱这个人，但我不能确定我能不能信任他。
You didn't fully possess him.
你并没有完全占有他。
I didn't fully possess him. And I think part of it was I didn't want to be fully possessed.
我并没有完全占有他。而且我觉得其中一部分是我也不想被完全占有。
Back when she was in her non-monogamous relationship, all her straight friends thought she was crazy. Her gay friends, however, were supportive and provided her and her boyfriend with role models. Non-monogamy is more common among gay couples than straight or lesbian couples. It makes some gay politicos uncomfortable when anyone points this out. But every study of long-term male couples has demonstrated this. Sometimes, gay couples even skip a formal rules conversation, so established are non-monogamous relationship models in the gay community.
当她处于非一夫一妻制关系时，所有的异性恋朋友都认为她疯了。然而，她的同性恋朋友给予了支持，并为她和她的男友提供了榜样。非一夫一妻制在同性恋伴侣中比在异性恋或女同性恋伴侣中更为普遍。当有人指出这一点时，会让一些同性恋政客感到不舒服。但每一项关于长期男性伴侣的研究都证明了这一点。有时，同性恋伴侣甚至跳过正式的规则谈话，因为非一夫一妻制的伴侣模式在同性恋社区中已经非常成熟。
I think non-monogamy is easier for a lot of gay men because gay men think about sex differently than straight people do. We recognize that different sex acts carry different degrees of intimacy. Many non-monogamous gay couples have a rule that stems from this commonsense notion. Outside sex is OK, goes the rule, so long as it does not include penetration. This rule allows for outside encounters, protects both partners from disease, and holds in reserve a few especially intimate sex acts that the gay couple, while non-monogamous, share only with each other. Since so many straight people-- not all, but many-- can't imagine having sex without intercourse, this rule just wouldn't work as well for them. My friend Dave is gay, and he's currently in a non-monogamous relationship.
我认为非一夫一妻制对很多男同性恋来说更容易，因为男同性恋对性的思考方式与异性恋者不同。我们认识到不同的性行为带有不同程度的亲密感。许多非一夫一妻制的男同性恋伴侣有一条源于这种常识性观念的规则。外部性关系是可以的，规则是，只要它不包括插入。这条规则允许外部邂逅，保护双方免受疾病侵扰，并保留了一些非常私密的性行为，即男同性恋伴侣，虽然是非一夫一妻制，但只与彼此分享。由于许多异性恋者——不是全部，但很多——无法想象没有性交的性关系，这条规则对他们来说就不那么管用了。我的朋友戴夫是同性恋，他目前处于非一夫一妻制关系中。
The rules we set down came about without really speaking of them. We just had a friend over, and things got kind of saucy. And we found ourselves goofing around with a third person. And--
我们制定的规则是在没有真正谈论的情况下产生的。我们只是有个朋友过来，事情变得有点俏皮。我们发现自己在和第三个人嬉闹。然后——
Very often, when gay men talk about these open arrangements or something, they'll use words and phrases like "goofing around" or "playing," and all these sort of harmless sounding-- whereas when straight people talk about it, it's like you "had sex" with another person. One of the things about gay sex that I sometimes think straight people have a hard time understanding is the possibility of having sort of Boy Scouty, camaraderie sex, where you're just sort of goofing around, to get back to that phrase. You think that's part of the difference between--
通常情况下，当男同性恋谈论这些开放安排或其他什么时，他们会使用“嬉闹”或“玩耍”之类的词汇，所有这些听起来无害的词——而当异性恋者谈论它时，就像是你和另一个人“发生了性关系”。关于男同性恋性行为，我有时觉得异性恋者很难理解的一点是，可能存在一种童子军式的、同志间的性行为，你只是在“嬉闹”，回到那个词。你觉得那是……之间的区别的一部分吗？
Absolutely. It truly is goofing around. It's mashing, it's making out, it's rolling around, because it's got to stay physically very superficial.
绝对是。它真的是在嬉闹。是揉搓，是亲热，是打滚，因为身体上必须保持非常肤浅。
As I said earlier, I was in three non-monogamous relationships-- past tense. All of them ended. And the woman I spoke with earlier is no longer in her non-monogamous relationship. Judging from just her and me, you would think non-monogamous relationships don't last. Well, you'd be wrong.
正如我早些时候说的，我曾有三段非一夫一妻制关系——过去式。都结束了。我早些时候采访的那位女性也不再处于非一夫一妻制关系中。单从她和我的经历来看，你会认为非一夫一妻制关系不会持久。嗯，那你错了。
Dr. Arline Rubin conducted the single largest study comparing non-monogamous couples to monogamous ones. Dr. Rubin interviewed 164 couples, half monogamous, half not, and did follow-up interviews with all 164 couples after 5, 10, and 19 years. Dr. Rubin discovered that there was no difference. Non-monogamous couples were just as happy or just as miserable as monogamous ones. And the number of couples who stayed together was exactly the same. Non-monogamy was no indication of instability or a lack of commitment. According to Dr. Rubin, whether a couple is monogamous has nothing to do with how long they stay together. Dave and his boyfriend, Eric, had been together for five years, and they're still going strong.
阿琳·鲁宾博士进行了规模最大的比较非一夫一妻制伴侣与一夫一妻制伴侣的研究。鲁宾博士采访了164对伴侣，一半一夫一妻制，一半不是，并在5年、10年和19年后对所有164对伴侣进行了后续访谈。鲁宾博士发现没有任何区别。非一夫一妻制的伴侣和一夫一妻制的伴侣一样快乐或一样痛苦。在一起的伴侣数量完全一样。非一夫一妻制并非不稳定或缺乏承诺的迹象。据鲁宾博士说，伴侣是否一夫一妻与他们在一起能走多远无关。戴夫和他的男友埃里克已经在一起五年了，而且依然稳固。
What would you say to people who assert that monogamy in a relationship is an indication of the seriousness of the relationship? That if two people are being monogamous, obviously, they're in it for the long haul, and they take their relationship seriously, and they put each other first, whereas if people are in a non-monogamous relationship, obviously, they're more casual about each other and their relationship isn't going to last as long.
你会对那些断言关系中的一夫一妻制是关系严肃性的标志的人说些什么？如果两个人是一夫一妻制，显而易见，他们是奔着长远去的，他们认真对待这段关系，把对方放在第一位，而如果人们处于非一夫一妻制关系中，显而易见，他们对彼此更随意，关系也不会维持那么久。
As for the first part of that, that monogamy is the sign of a true relationship, I would say, if it's true for you, then it's true. As for the assumption that a non-monogamous relationship is inherently less valuable or less committed, I would disagree just on the fact that the conversations that Eric and I have had to have in maintaining a somewhat open relationship have brought about a level of intimacy we wouldn't have tapped any other way.
关于那第一部分，即一夫一妻制是真实关系的标志，我会说，如果它对你是真的，那么它就是真的。至于非一夫一妻制关系本质上价值较低或缺乏承诺的假设，我不同意，单凭我和埃里克为了维持某种开放关系所必须进行的对话，就带来了我们无法通过其他任何方式达到的亲密程度。
I mean, it seems like everybody talks about monogamy as something that you do for somebody else, that I will be faithful to you because I love you. But I actually came to feel like non-monogamy was something that you could do for somebody else. You could let them be who they were and still love them and still be committed to them.
我的意思是，似乎每个人都谈论一夫一妻制，认为那是你为别人做的事，因为我爱你，所以我会对你忠诚。但我实际上开始觉得，非一夫一妻制也是你可以为别人做的事。你可以让他们成为他们自己，依然爱他们，依然承诺他们。
The other assumption that is often made about non-monogamy is that it's a phase. A couple may open their relationship for a time, but they will, once they get serious, return to monogamy. Dr. Rubin's studies have shown that this isn't true either. The couples she followed, all straight and now all in their late 50s and 60s, with houses, mortgages, and kids, as their marriages went on, these couples pretty much stuck to what they'd been doing all along, whether it was monogamy or non-monogamy. So it isn't an experiment or a phase. It's a choice. And like Dave says, it works for the couples that it works for.
关于非一夫一妻制的另一个假设是它是一个阶段。伴侣可能会在一段时间内开放关系，但一旦他们认真起来，就会回归一夫一妻制。鲁宾博士的研究表明这也不是真的。她追踪的伴侣，全是异性恋，现在都在50多岁和60多岁，有房、有贷款、有孩子，随着婚姻的继续，这些伴侣基本上坚持了他们一直在做的事情，无论是一夫一妻制还是非一夫一妻制。所以这不是实验或阶段。这是一种选择。正如戴夫所说，它对那些适用的伴侣来说是有效的。
Dan Savage writes a syndicated sex advice column, Savage Love . He also works at The Stranger , a newspaper in Seattle.
丹·萨维奇撰写辛迪加性咨询专栏《萨维奇之爱》。他还在西雅图的《陌生人》报社工作。
Act Three, Istanbul. So where does this leave most of us, the rest of us? Where does it leave those of us who understand what it is that we actually sacrifice to be monogamous-- adventure, surprise-- but also understand what we would be sacrificing, what difficulties and jealousies we might be subjecting ourselves to if we were non-monogamous? Where does this leave us? Well, Ian Brown has these thoughts.
第三幕：伊斯坦布尔。那么这对我们大多数人，我们其余人意味着什么？对于我们这些明白为了维持一夫一妻制而牺牲了什么——冒险、惊喜——但同时也明白如果我们是非一夫一妻制，我们会牺牲什么，会遭受什么困难和嫉妒的人来说，这意味着什么？这对我们意味着什么？嗯，伊恩·布朗有这些想法。
There's a couple across my street who make love in their living room. I hear them in the evening when I walk after dinner. From the sidewalk, I can see cream walls, a mantel draped in animal hides, African carvings. The woman makes most of the noise, mid-range "ohs" a second apart, dropping like small, crystal cups out of the open French windows of their flat. Passion and disregard for the neighbors, a tremendous combination. The air stops moving around me.
在我家街道对面有一对夫妻在客厅里做爱。晚上散步回来我能听到他们的声音。从人行道上，我可以看到奶油色的墙壁，壁炉台上披着兽皮，还有非洲木雕。那个女人发出的声音最多，中间间隔一秒发出中音的“哦”声，像小小的水晶杯一样从他们公寓敞开的法式窗户里落下。激情和无视邻居，一种极好的组合。空气在我周围停止了流动。
Is their sex better than my own? I wonder what she looks like when she's moaning. Does she love him? Presuming it's a him, which I always do. Or is she there just for the sex? I can never decide which would be more exciting. I imagine she's in her 30s and that she has dark hair, an ordinary woman with ordinary chores, whose passion is nonetheless excitingly unsuppressable in the evening. But which woman is it? Is the moaner the doctor who just had a baby, only now returning to sex? The Mexican girl who works out all the time at the gym? Or the Chinese caterer, the woman who drives the Volvo with Ohio license plates?
他们的性生活比我的更好吗？我好奇她呻吟时是什么样子。她爱他吗？假设是一个他，我总是这么想。还是她只是为了性？我永远无法决定哪一个更令人兴奋。我想象她30多岁，留着黑发，一个有着平凡家务的平凡女人，尽管如此，她的激情在晚上却令人兴奋地无法抑制。但那是哪个女人？呻吟的是那个刚生了孩子、现在才恢复性生活的医生吗？那个总是去健身房锻炼的墨西哥女孩？还是那个中国餐饮供应商，开着挂俄亥俄州车牌沃尔沃的那个女人？
Her cries never last more than half a block. Walking back to my house, I usually have a few bent, embarrassed thoughts. I think, you're a 39-year-old married man who stands in front of his house, listening to an unseen couple make love. You're sick. But I keep stepping out there, hoping to hear that little duet.
她的哭喊声从未持续超过半个街区。走回我的房子，我通常会有一些弯曲、尴尬的想法。我想，你是一个39岁的已婚男人，站在自己家门前，听着一对看不见的夫妇做爱。你病了。但我还是不停地走出来，希望听到那段小二重唱。
My wife wants to have a baby. And it's not just talk or a plan she inherited at birth or the fantasizing she used to practice with her girlfriends-- "Well, I want to have four." No, this is different, more insistent.
我的妻子想要个孩子。这不是随口说说，也不是她生来继承的计划，或者她以前和女朋友练习的幻想——“好吧，我想生四个。”不，这是不同的，更坚持。
"When would you like to start?" she said again this morning, third time in a week, as we read the newspaper over breakfast. The sun was already bearing down furiously at half past 8:00 in the goddamn morning. I could hear the buzz of a weed whacker next door. "Anytime you like," I said, not taking my eyes off the paper. I didn't want to encourage her because the truth is this. Some days, I'm for it. But when I'm not for it, I'm really not for it.
“你想什么时候开始？”她今天早上又说了一遍，这一周第三次，我们在吃早餐时看报纸。太阳早上八点半就已经极其猛烈地照射下来。我能听到隔壁割草机的嗡嗡声。“随时都可以，”我说，眼睛没有离开报纸。我不想鼓励她，因为事实是这样的。有些日子，我赞成。但当我不赞成时，我是真的很不赞成。
My wife's body has changed. Her body, overtaken by hormonal committee, is telling her to get on with its grandest physical purpose. I can see it in the slight post-marital widening of her hips, no less sexy than the originals, but still, wider, when she lilts away from the bed at night to perform her ablutions. I can see it in her taste in clothes. She doesn't go anymore for the sprayed-on Lycra skirts I used to buy her. Even in her sexual habits-- she has less interest in sex than she used to. She wants to make love now, for keeps. Pause here for sadness.
我妻子的身体变了。她的身体，被荷尔蒙委员会接管，正告诉她去完成它最宏大的生理目的。我能看到她婚后臀部略微变宽，并不比最初的少性感，但依然，更宽，当她晚上轻快地离开床去洗漱时。我能从她的衣着品味中看到。她不再追求我以前给她买的喷涂式莱卡短裙。甚至在她的性习惯上——她对性的兴趣比以前少了。她现在想要认真做爱，为了永久。这里暂停一下以示悲伤。
Last week, as if by magic, two baby books appeared in the pile on the floor on her side of the bed-- at the bottom of the pile, but there they were. I walked into the bedroom, saw them like a promise I made long ago, and had to leave the house. I went to a matinee.
上周，仿佛有魔力一样，两本育儿书出现在她床边地板上的那一堆书中——在堆的最下面，但它们就在那。我走进卧室，看到它们就像我很久以前做出的承诺，不得不离开房子。我去看了一场日场电影。
When did all that happen? I can't remember anything. The dates of our courtship, the countless touching things she claims I said, they're at best a blur to me, a fog of declarations. One day, I was living my comfortable life. And the next, she was living with me. On a bad day, it makes me nervous to remember all this. On a bad day, when I think about the slow gelling of our togetherness, its gathering weight and formality, the muscle around my heart closes in and my breath come short and I start to panic. One day, she and I were dating. And then we were living together. And then we bought a house. And then we'd married. And then she wanted to have a baby. An escalator of commitments onto which I had apparently stepped.
这一切是什么时候发生的？我不记得任何事。我们求爱的日子，她声称我说过的无数感人的话，对我来说充其量是一片模糊，是一团宣言的迷雾。有一天，我过着舒适的生活。第二天，她就和我住在一起。在糟糕的日子里，回想起这一切让我紧张。在糟糕的日子里，当我想到我们在一起的缓慢凝固、它聚集的重量和形式感时，我心脏周围的肌肉紧缩，呼吸急促，开始恐慌。有一天，她和我在约会。然后我们住在一起。然后我们买了房子。然后我们结婚了。然后她想要个孩子。这是一场我显然踏上的承诺的自动扶梯。
My friends were astonished. They said I wasn't the type to marry. A few of them had made bets against it. I told them I wanted "to find out what lay on the other side of boredom." I stole that line from an old girlfriend. I thought I was an adventurer. And yet, here I stand, in a well-trimmed front yard, surrounded by neighbors and swing sets and sport utility vehicles, the movable monuments of domesticity, listening to a couple copulate. And across the yards, I see another man looking warily back at me, doing exactly the same thing.
我的朋友们惊呆了。他们说我不是那种会结婚的人。他们中有几个人赌过我不会结。我告诉他们我想“去看看乏味的另一边是什么”。我从一个老女友那里偷了那句话。我以为我是个冒险家。然而，我站在这里，在修剪得很好的前院里，被邻居、秋千架和运动型多功能车所包围，这些家庭生活的移动纪念碑，听着一对夫妇交媾。而在院子对面，我看到另一个男人警惕地看着我，做着完全一样的事情。
Just because I'm married now and practicing what's known as monogamy doesn't mean I don't think about other women, because I do. I still conjure up women from my past. And I still ask myself the question. You know the question. Every man does. Women have their own version of it. The question is the question you ask yourself every time you see a woman on the street, every single time, no matter who she is, how old she is, no matter how attractive she is or isn't. And the question is, "Would I sleep with her, or her, or how about her?" Not "Will I sleep with her?" or "How can I sleep with her?" or even "Could I sleep with her?" The question is, "Would I?" But even though I always ask the question, I don't act on it, because I'm trying to be monogamous.
仅仅因为我现在结婚了，并且在练习所谓的一夫一妻制，并不意味着我不考虑其他女人，因为我有。我依然唤起我过去的女人。而且我依然问自己这个问题。你知道那个问题。每个男人都会。女人有她们自己的版本。这个问题是你每次在街上看到一个女人时问自己的问题，每一次，无论她是哪个人，无论她多大年纪，无论她有多吸引人或不吸引人。这个问题是，“我会和她睡吗，或者她，或者她怎么样？”不是“我会和她睡吗？”或“我怎么能和她睡？”甚至“我能和她睡吗？”这个问题是，“我会吗？”但尽管我总是问这个问题，我并没有付诸行动，因为我在努力做到一夫一妻制。
That's why monogamy has such a bad reputation. It's boring. Monogamy is the habit of not acting on what you want. I even hate the word itself. It sound so staid, so bourgeois. Monogamy, like a board game, the approximation of excitement.
这就是为什么一夫一妻制名声这么差。它很乏味。一夫一妻制是习惯于不去行动你想要的。我甚至讨厌这个词本身。它听起来太一本正经，太资产阶级了。一夫一妻制，就像一个棋盘游戏，对兴奋的近似。
Sometimes, of course, I hear about open marriages. Jung had one, Sartre had one, Henry Miller, Dickens, Freud. I hear about open marriages, and they seem like some fabulous, exotic city that I've always wanted to visit but never seem to get to. Istanbul. Open marriages are like Istanbul, some ancient, mysterious place where there are minarets and strange music, where one entire civilization suddenly ends and a whole new, stranger one begins. A whole new religion, even, the mysterious East. I've always wanted to go to Istanbul.
有时，当然，我听说开放式婚姻。荣格有一个，萨特有一个，亨利·米勒，狄更斯，弗洛伊德。我听说开放式婚姻，它们看起来像是一个我一直想去但似乎从未到达的奇妙、异国情调的城市。伊斯坦布尔。开放式婚姻就像伊斯坦布尔，一些古老、神秘的地方，那里有宣礼塔和奇怪的音乐，那里一个完整的文明突然结束，而一个全新的、更陌生的文明开始。甚至是一个全新的宗教，神秘的东方。我一直想去伊斯坦布尔。
Like most couples, my wife and I sometimes talk about open marriage. Well, I say we talk about it. It'd be more accurate to say that the subject comes up and immediately lies down again. We'll be lying in bed in the dark and talking about our lives, about what we like and what we miss, in that quiet, pleasant way you do when you're trying to be monogamous. Then my wife will say in the dark, "You know, if you ever have sex with someone else, some passing fling, I don't want you to tell me about it." And I say, "Really?"
像大多数夫妻一样，我和妻子有时会谈论开放式婚姻。嗯，我说我们谈论它。更准确地说，这个话题会浮现出来，然后立刻又躺下去了。我们会躺在黑暗的床上谈论我们的生活，谈论我们喜欢的和我们错过的，以那种你试图维持一夫一妻制时那种安静、愉快的方式。然后我的妻子会在黑暗中说：“你知道，如果你哪天和别人发生了性关系，一些短暂的艳遇，我不想让你告诉我。”我说：“真的吗？”
I say, "Really?" because I don't know what else to say. If I say, "OK, Honey, that's fine with me," she'll say, "What, are you thinking about it?" And then I'll have to say, "Of course not," even if I am. So I say, "Really?" Or I'll say something noncommittal, like, "Don't worry." Whatever I say, a few minutes go by. And then she always says, still in the dark, "But I don't want you to sleep with someone else, anyway. OK?" And I say, "OK." That's the kind of conversation you have when you agree to be monogamous.
我说，“真的吗？”是因为我不知道还能说什么。如果我说，“好的，亲爱的，我没问题，”她会说，“怎么，你在想那件事吗？”然后我就必须说，“当然没有，”即使我是在想。所以我说，“真的吗？”或者我会说一些不置可否的话，比如，“别担心。”无论我说什么，几分钟过去了。然后她总是说，依然在黑暗中，“但我还是不希望你和别人睡觉，好吗？”我说，“好。”这就是你同意维持一夫一妻制时进行的谈话。
I don't want to sleep with anyone else. Or to be more exact, I'd like to, but I really don't have the constitution for infidelity or for an open marriage or for the guilt. Monogamy may be boring, but the alternatives take up a lot more time and energy. When I hear stories about the president and I think, he must have an arrangement with Hillary, I think, gee, that must be great.
我不想和别人睡觉。或者说得更确切些，我想，但我真的没有不忠或者开放式婚姻或者内疚的体质。一夫一妻制可能很无聊，但其他的选择需要花费更多的时间和精力。当我听到关于总统的故事，我想，他肯定和希拉里有某种安排，我想，哎呀，那一定很棒。
But some part of me also feels-- not disappointed, not morally outraged, nothing that loud and sharp and pompous, but-- sad. That's the word-- sad. And I'm not sure I know why. I'm not even sure I know why I'm trying to stay monogamous. Why have I chosen this route over the other? I don't pretend it has anything to do with moral standards. In fact, I suspect it comes down to something my wife once said to me.
但我也觉得内心某一部分——不是失望，不是道德愤怒，没有那么大声、尖锐和自以为是，而是——悲伤。就是这个词——悲伤。而且我不确定我知道为什么。我甚至不确定我知道为什么我在努力维持一夫一妻制。为什么我选择了这条路线而不是另一条？我不假装它与道德标准有任何关系。事实上，我怀疑这归结于我妻子曾经对我说的某句话。
We were having one of our conversational minuets in the dark, one of our gentle but ever so delicate chats about faithfulness, when my wife said that the only thing she missed as a monogamous woman-- at least I assume she was speaking as a monogamous woman-- was newness, new bodies, new hands, new sex. I said I knew what she meant. And I said, "But isn't that kind of sad? I mean, if you go through your whole life, 20, 30, 40, 60 years of marriage without ever straying, you do that, you never get to know what it's like to be unfaithful. You never get to know what it feels like to be emotionally illegal. And that's an important feeling, one of the great human themes, after all, a whole constellation of humanity you'll never know."
我们在黑暗中进行着我们的谈话小步舞，我们关于忠诚的温柔但非常微妙的聊天，当时我的妻子说，作为一个一夫一妻制的女人她错过的唯一东西——至少我假设她是以一个一夫一妻制的女人的身份发言的——是新奇感，新的身体，新的手，新的性。我说我明白她的意思。我说，“但那不是有点悲伤吗？我的意思是，如果你的一生，20、30、40、60年的婚姻都没有出轨，你做到了，你永远无法知道不忠是什么感觉。你永远无法知道在情感上违法是什么感觉。毕竟，那是一种重要的感觉，是伟大的人类主题之一，那是一整个你永远不会知道的人类星群。”
My wife was quiet for a long time. And I could hear the fridge downstairs. And in the street light coming through the curtains, I could just see her outline. And I thought to myself, I've spent a long time in this bed. "Yes," my wife said then, "That's true. But if you do sleep around, you'll never know what it's like to be faithful to one person your whole life, which might also be an 'important constellation of humanity.'" There was just a touch of sarcasm in her voice.
我的妻子沉默了很久。我能听到楼下冰箱的声音。从窗帘中射进来的街灯光中，我只能看到她的轮廓。我对自己想，我在床上待了很长时间。“是的，”我妻子那时说，“那是真的。但如果你真的到处乱搞，你就永远不会知道对一个人忠诚一生是什么感觉，那可能也是一种‘重要的人类星群’。”她的语气里带着一丝讽刺。
And then it was my turn to lie in the dark for a long time. I'd never considered monogamy as an adventure. I thought it was, well, domestic travel, where no international borders are crossed. But monogamy is an adventure, and in some ways, a more mysterious one than open marriage. Because trying to be faithful to one person is a trip that takes time. And you never really know if you're getting close or if you've reached the destination. You never really know when you've arrived.
然后轮到我躺在黑暗中很久了。我从未把一夫一妻制当作一种冒险。我以为它是，嗯，国内旅行，不会跨越任何国际边界。但一夫一妻制是一种冒险，在某些方面，比开放式婚姻更神秘。因为试图对一个人忠诚是一段需要时间的旅程。你永远不知道你是否接近了，或者你是否到达了目的地。你永远不知道你何时到达了。
For my generation-- the first one that assumed free love for both sexes was a birthright-- for us, monogamy is the last sexual mystery on Earth, the great unknown. We've tried everything else. It's certainly a different kind of trip than open marriage, which has lots of stops along the way. But most of them are the same. Maybe that's the problem with open marriage-- not many surprises. It's titillating, but not very mysterious. Maybe that's why hearing about open marriages always makes me a little sad, why there's always a whiff of defeat about them.
对于我们这一代人——第一代把男女自由恋爱当作与生俱来的权利的一代——对我们来说，一夫一妻制是地球上最后一个性之谜，伟大的未知。我们尝试了一切其他的东西。它当然与开放式婚姻那种沿途有很多停靠点的旅程不同。但其中大多数都是一样的。也许这就是开放式婚姻的问题——惊喜不多。它令人兴奋，但不怎么神秘。也许这就是为什么听说开放式婚姻总是让我有点悲伤，为什么它们总有一种失败的气息。
I lay there in the dark beside my wife, thinking about all this, as I say, for a long time. I thought about that dream of hers, to be faithful her whole life. I thought, it's a sweet dream, almost like an ideal. And I knew I didn't want to be the one to prove to her that it couldn't come true. It scared me, too, all that responsibility, because it's not such a wise thing to promise.
我躺在妻子身边的黑暗中，思考这一切，如我所说，很长一段时间。我想到了她那个梦想，一生对她忠诚。我想，这是一个甜蜜的梦想，几乎像一种理想。我知道我不想成为那个证明给她看它无法实现的人。它也吓到了我，所有那些责任，因为它不是一个聪明的承诺。
Anyway, I'm trying to be monogamous, maybe not even for myself. Maybe I'm just doing it for her. Is that so unusual? Maybe if I do it for her long enough, I'll start to do it for me, as well. It's not that I don't want to go to Istanbul anymore. I really want to. In fact, I think about Istanbul all the time, if only to remind myself that it's still there. It's just that there's this other place I want to get to first, a little town that, for the longest time, I never even knew was there.
总之，我正在努力维持一夫一妻制，也许甚至不是为了我自己。也许我只是为了她才这么做。这很反常吗？也许如果我为了她坚持得足够久，我也会开始为自己这么做。不是我不想去伊斯坦布尔了。我真的很想。事实上，我一直都在想伊斯坦布尔，哪怕只是提醒自己它还在那里。只是有另一个地方我想先去，一个小镇，很长一段时间，我甚至不知道它的存在。
Ian Brown is the host of Talking Books on the Sunday edition of CBC's This Morning . Part of his comments are from his book Man Medium Rare.
伊恩·布朗是加拿大广播公司《今晨》周日版《谈论书籍》节目的主持人。他的部分评论摘自他的书《男人，中熟》。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder. Senior editor Paul Tough, contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Rachel Day, Jorge Just, Todd Bachmann, and Sylvia Lemus.
嗯，我们今天的节目是由艾莉克斯·斯皮格尔和我自己制作的，还有南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德。高级编辑保罗·塔夫，特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林，顾问萨拉·沃威尔。制作协助来自蕾切尔·戴、豪尔赫·贾斯特、托德·巴克曼和西尔维娅·莱姆斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you know you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想购买本节目的录音带，请致电芝加哥WBEZ，电话312-832-3380。或者你知道你可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org上免费收听我们的大部分节目。感谢运行该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who says about being a program director,
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他谈到担任项目主管时说，
It isn't an experiment or a phase. It's a choice.
这不是实验或阶段。这是一种选择。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带来更多美国生活的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台，PRI。